hello you're in for a crazy episode
today i'll let you see why
um i am coming and do it coming ew i'm
doing stand up you guys january 14th
i'll be at wise guys comedy club in salt
lake city january 21st zany's nashville
and then i'm coming to raleigh
cap city in austin indianapolis and
that's it i'll see you there tickets at
esteronice.com and sleepoverbyester.com
is my clothing line hello sluggies i am
back on the road i can't wait to see you
in this upcoming new year in january i
will be
in edmonton
canada alberta canada i will be at the
improv in milwaukee off the hook in
naples florida and side splitters in
tampa florida and a bunch more dates
coming up please look at annie letterman
dot com
shows come see me
[Music]
wait do you have that fantasy of just um
um
suckling on a teat no
she has a fantasy of suckling on a teeth
that used to have fake tits but now
doesn't have them are you into fake tits
uh this is i'm not fake are you into
augmented um breasts this is a christmas
episode and this is technically within
the confines of the wholesome 10. what
did i teach you earlier what's this
phrase that i told you to say
a manakalia a wacky talk
how do we say merry christmas
holocaust esther that never happened
everybody welcome to the show
come on now we don't talk about those
such things by the way
when we go to the scope this is we're in
kalila's hometown right now the hometown
dates you guys i don't live here well
i'm not this is my hometown kalila's
pretending she doesn't live here i don't
live here we go to skokie we're going
the holocaust museum annie that sounds
like a blast esther please take me
whatever i can't wait
any
any vacation with esther is very
holocaust museum-ish
that's exactly how i would say it thank
you
thank you you're welcome so we're what
day three now day three days we should
probably recap what we did yesterday
where's my fan oh that's right let me
get my fan i'm i yesterday went so bad
for me that today i had to get high
right when i woke up why did you think
it went bad because my allergies ruined
my day
um
i i don't know
i forgot why you're on
i think i just had to get high today
but you were high yesterday weren't you
at night yeah well no not at night
esther you were so high during the
museum visit oh yeah i needed to really
have a spiritual experience there i
listen i'm going to tell you guys
something there will be a reel revealing
all of these things i'm working on a
reel right now an investigative reel
about
how esther got too high for a museum
it was i will tell you okay so it's a
museum that
of the islamic arts so all of the
artwork is symmetrical so it's supposed
to show the perfection of god so
everything is symmetrical all of their
artwork except there's always one
imperfection because they don't want to
be disrespectful to god oh yeah it kind
of so in this podcast esther you're the
imperfection
you're our smug did you hear what
happened on the rug when he explained
that how i was shouting yes i love this
no you were in another room esther
we lost esther there were like times we
lost we and we obviously were not
supposed to be in there okay our our
lovely tour guide i i think he probably
got in a little trouble
the security guard chased me out and was
like while we were leaving and was like
don't ever touch the art and i was like
i touched the art i don't even remember
touching the art i was like security
chased you out yes and he was really
upset and i was like oh my god if i did
i didn't mean to do it i'll never do it
again but he was so mad at me for
reference if you guys want to google
shangri-la it's like doris duke's home
and she endorsed a lifetime billionaire
heiress she's that she's the annie of
the podcast she if she were on the
podcast she'd be sitting in the middle
bill she built this amazing mansion
with all these not this part this isn't
part's not me
klyla you explain it so it just it was
really it was sick she took a voyage in
her 20s um around the world and she
landed in hawaii
she fell in love with the place but she
was also really into islamic art so she
collected that over like 60 years of her
life and it's all in his one home that
they call the shangri-la yeah and um she
left her husband for one of the island
boys she did yeah so she had like a she
had a this was supposed to be her summer
house in hawaii and then she ended up
living here full time and she was
banging
uh some young island boy i don't
remember which one i mean that's the
thing it's like i think what are your
thoughts on that i think can you ever go
to a place like this and not take on a
lover i listen i brought my young island
boy with me and he's right here
he's my island
i don't the hawaiian that's like not you
know what it is it's not your type the
whole thing you're racist
you didn't let me [ __ ] finish the
lifestyle that a hawaiian person leads
is very like laid back here you're on
the island like i'm more attracted to
someone who's like lives in a scared
like new york city like situation like
an italian greyhound yes that's the vibe
of a man that you like yeah she wants a
guy like you're not going to meet him
you're not going to meet him unless you
run into him like on an elevator
wait explain she wants someone from
succession no nobody no
no don't you have a crush on yeah ken
yeah kendall roy yeah look at her look
at her face i talked she wanted to
kendall roy that's why i'm like how do i
talk about it here i don't listen i'll
be honest esther i know like one of your
new bits and then i hear laughter i go
she's okay she doesn't need me and i sit
down i don't care what
you i know you know my whole act can you
imagine if i thought you were sitting in
the audience i know you're long gone
when i go on stage
long gone esther's in los feliz by the
time i set foot in west hollywood
okay so back to the museum visit it was
awesome it was really cool i did get
lost carlos and i got lost at one point
there's something with the acoustics in
the place where we could not hear where
you guys were it was like you were like
did they get raptured
did we like go vape outside and get like
we got we escaped the rapture
and then we went out and we were like
running through this field and i think
the security guard was mad about that
too because when we did find a guy
security twice when we came when we did
find you guys not michael uh navi the
guy that was giving us the tour
went did you have fun out there which
means he got walkie-talkie
about us running around
and i was like we did we actually did
have fun so would you say kylie your
experience doing a museum tour with
annie and esther like
one is like very clearly like the bad
kid and then the other is like the more
artsy like oh i wanna call you rc
i don't wanna tell yourself hi to be in
trouble
esther i'll post the pics it's coming
esther you were
in a different museum
you're in a museum um somewhere very
very very far away from where you were
in the museum of ham arts okay we're in
islam arts what's
what i don't know okay
esther was where was esther esther was
um definitely in the other room with
george's baby by the way i will say this
george
oh no
when you cam when you shut up with the
baby and it goes the tour guy goes
there's a lot of stairs
oh they like totally didn't want
george's baby to go
this is a baby free zone um
it was good but there was a lot of um it
is a baby free zone because doris duke
had a baby that only lived for a day
yeah oh they didn't want the baby in
there your living baby came in
here living baby into a woman's house
who had to mourn her baby doris duke did
seem it did seem kind of lonely like i
the idea of like collecting things from
like other parts of the world and owning
a piece of it there's a lot of
controversial art in there because some
of it was like sacred from tombs that
shouldn't have been taken and they were
stolen but i think that's a conversation
around like all museums nowadays is like
repatriating or repatriation just in
general like returning things to where
like they were originally from but he
was saying like certain things would
have been
bombed out yeah it would be just nothing
yeah do you want it destroyed um
but so day two i would say was
relatively successful for us as a group
i will say that we didn't make it to the
strip club we did not make it to strip
club i think esther um called that one
off first although we were all we were
all pretty tired that makes me happy
because i i was pretty worried i was
like oh are they going to be upset but i
was so tired at 8 30 i fell asleep like
i passed here's this is what i'm
learning about vacation okay you need to
jam pack your day with stuff todd and i
were talking about this on the way over
jam pack your day with stuff so you are
tired but if you do want to do something
like a strip club you have to accompany
it you have to attach it to a dinner
yeah so when you go home it's still
light out it's right before dinner time
i don't want to be so when you go for a
strip club but you don't need a lot you
don't need a lot i cannot not do that
i've watched it this time [ __ ] i know
you're eating patterns now
we worked out together now we're bound
we went out to breakfast she wasn't
eating the carbs you have to tell me
ahead of time we're not eating carbs if
i think you're eating the carbs i go
carbs first okay if we worked out
together that day we're on the same
eating pattern right here's the thing
you have to eat all the healthy things
up front so you're too full to eat the
unhealthy things on the back end however
i've never had the i never had the
grilled
biscuit i thought maybe we were on a
special you went biscuit first on your
breakfast when we ordered the exact same
thing
i feel left out
look we ordered the same thing for
breakfast because we worked out together
and i ate the eggs and the meat first
you told us you don't have neck muscles
i didn't know that you could exercise
esther is still there's a running theory
that esther has that she has no neck
muscles you are using my weaknesses
against me
okay the doctor told me that in private
esther you have no neck muscles all of
these things that aren't a thing that
could possibly happen happen in a
private room with this doctor that
doesn't exist okay it's carlos's dad
there's gonna be and we wanna thank
carlos's dad for sponsoring this podcast
there's gonna be a private room at the
strip club with your name on it little
girl
and it's just a doctor in there telling
you there's things wrong with you
that's how you get your jollies off you
look like you give a nice laugh dance in
that outfit your little cute little horn
you may be deceived they did i do want
to be a little piggy we didn't choose
people listen he got these outfits for
us okay underneath
george
under georgia's great job painting and
then he later great job
by the way i'm the grandma [ __ ] you
ew you're period showing nothing
i would have much rather in that i would
have much rather been in that outfit
esther i promise you i don't know how
this i have the best outfit yeah you do
but i will tell you they have like up
your [ __ ] underwear they got me so it
was supposed to be just this and it's up
like in it
wow oh it's inside yeah i don't think
it's inside ones i don't think it's
supposed to go in no it is there's only
a little string
it's a string thong that goes into the
front annie it's not supposed to go in
there you put the song part up your
[ __ ] it's not there's not another
option
it's just a string oh okay it's just a
string across it's this pervert pete and
his he's home with his family his
perverted family help me i got you guys
presents can i give you guys yeah what i
didn't know it was the christmas episode
you didn't know it was the christmas
episode i did look i got christmas
jordans guys i mailed this outfit holy
[ __ ] i got these ahead of time they came
into i put the [ __ ] red laces in i
want a lap dance for you i'm going to
show you do you want to see my
thing
oh my god
it's in her vagina
annie that's a medical malfunction oh
[ __ ] you're waiting for that's a ph
imbalance waiting to happen that's right
baby i'm gonna get a beastie yeasty on
an island
okay
i wanna go home all right so this is for
i have four presents i gotta give them
in a certain order okay kalyla this is
for you oh my god yes
show everyone the present
uh it's a calendar that says men of the
hawaiian islands oh i wonder what
calendar i'm gonna get one
this happens
for esther
[Applause]
i have one for george
george this is one of all the places you
can't go because you brought your family
with you
so you brought your [ __ ] baby we have
no vacation what does it say he's stuck
in a hotel room raining with his wife
they get up at four they have to get up
at 4am because the baby's on la time and
they have to wait for places to open eat
breakfast they're starving to death on
their own
george is having the number one worst
vacation of his life the first place
opens at 6 00 a.m and there's a line by
605. okay now carlos i got one carlos i
got this one i will say that george i
got this one
carlos also against the man the hawaiian
islands
carlos you and i we're calendar twins
i've been dying to give you those
presents
[Laughter]
george i will say this that he's still
looking at it carlos gave it a real deep
look i'll tell you that he really
checked that bit out
i'm not shy i like mine oh look at those
but i want to see the guys i want to
look at the guys
have you backed any of them i probably
at least four of the
12 on here let me let me take a closer
look this episode is
the holiday seasons or as i like to call
it the holiday seasonal affective
disorder times are it's it's depression
time guys
we all regress when we go see our
families life is hard you might you
might be at home with your family
stressed out you might be in hawaii with
your co-workers wanting to kill each
other it's hard nonetheless regardless
you need better help check out
betterhelp.com trash tuesday betterhelp
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist and connect in a safe and
private online environment it is so
convenient and you can start
communicating in under 48 hours you can
send a message to your counselor anytime
and you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions which annie
maybe you should uh schedule one for
tonight yeah you know what's weird when
you guys sometimes people like it's rude
annie's looking at her phone well i'm
actually texting my therapist okay she's
journal entry i'm letting them know
what's going on giving them the update
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed which is
come on guys it's you're not going to
get you're not going to match with your
it's too hard i've gone through so many
therapists uh they've gone through you
it's let's be real
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available and this service is available
for clients worldwide we want you to
start living a happier life today as a
listener you'll get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over 1 million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health again that's
betterhelp.help.comtrashtuesday
you guys
extra is the first debit card that lets
you build your credit and earn reward
points just like a credit card um i will
say that as someone that has recently
crawled my
butt out of debt
this is really helpful this is amazing
todd uses it i use it today there are
over 100 million americans who don't
want or can't get a credit card
honestly that was one that was me once
upon a time yes that was me very
recently before this and i'll tell you
thank you for this because now they are
giving me credit cards and i will be
needing you again very soon this is like
i was born to do this ad because when i
first started dating my first boyfriend
in la he didn't have a credit card or a
bank account and i dragged his ass to
chase bank and i like started a whole
fight with all the banks i was like give
this man a bank account
today there are over 100 million
americans who don't want or can't get a
credit card yet there are very few
alternatives for establishing your
credit other than with a risky credit
card their mission is to make credit
building safer and more accessible for
everyone so there are no credit checks
there is no interest and extra spots you
and pays themselves back the next
business day so you as a user can
connect extra to your existing bank
account and then extra spots you for
everyday purchases and then they ought
to pay as a user you can auto pay
extra on the next business days yeah
you're not going into debt with them
you're paying them back they're going to
make sure that they get their payment
back at the end of the month all
payments are tallied up and reported to
credit bureaus users also earn
redeemable reward points for every
purchase they make so if you're someone
who needs to build credit but like can't
really do it in a risky way this is the
perfect way for you to dip your toe in
and get in the game you guys can get
extra today to start building credit
with debit go to extra dot app slash
trash tuesday and start rebuilding your
credit safely with the extra debit card
no interest rates credit checks or
hidden fees that's extra dot app app
slash trash tuesday and here's the
little debit card it comes with
can we talk about the rape room okay
wait we have one okay a lot happened
esther you left okay you left you left
danny should we talk about the way
so crazy say i left they literally left
me in a different car but i left that's
so like how you you should you were so
excited you were just you're like nerd
it was your fault we did well maybe get
the [ __ ] hint [ __ ] and stop being
such a nerd
we didn't want you leaking your period
blood everywhere we're trying to hang
out i would have you wait i just went
about carlos he came back to the hotel
room last night and he walked in and i
heard the toilet flush and i was like oh
sorry did i leave my tampon in there
he's like yeah you're not just a flush
tampon
twice
at least you didn't leave it out have
you ever forgotten sometimes i wrap it
up and i leave it out have you ever had
a guy take it out for you before he has
sex with you on your period no
um i have i had that but it was in
germany when i was 15. of course i'd be
in germany and of course she'd be
underage you were 15. we threw out the
window yeah wait wait have you done that
yeah
15. maybe as a as a teenager you're not
like as in squeamish about what they're
going to see no not at all why not um
they should know about the clots yeah we
should know it is gross this is the
thing when guys are like oh it's gross
don't tell us about it it's like no no
it is gross and you do need to know get
to know it
it's so much grosser than you think we
don't talk about the diarrhea we keep
the diarrhea a secret i don't poo in
front of lovers i no i have a strictly i
have a strict open door open bathroom
door policy in my relationship
todd has to make direct eye contact for
me for the poop to plop out oh my god
todd ain't that right baby
oh my god he's watching sports wearing
his football he bet on sports i support
this annie how does it feel knowing that
your
boyfriend and i wear the same shoes that
you wear the same shoes
do you get turned on i do think like
metaphorically you do wear the same
shoes you are kind of like
good to have a round but not fully
necessary you know it's not
it's a bonus
um no you guys both have yeezys i like
that i like
no anytime you spend money i'm happy
when you have things that my people have
my rich people have then by the way this
is this is the trip everyone's summed up
annie just wants all of us to spend all
our money
all of our money
is having the worst vacation in my life
kalila this is what's so sad okay i
realize what it is with kala because i
was like she's melancholy like she's i'm
talking to her she's annoyed i go it's
because this [ __ ] is she's like the
movie where they [ __ ] the fish you know
which one the movie where they [ __ ] the
fish at the end um the one the guillermo
del toro movie the guillermo de toro
movie where he [ __ ] the fish
that is kalila kalila needs to be with
the water she's a bee with the fish
the rain has ruined her life i haven't
been able to [ __ ] fish on this trip but
you but you know what i mean like i mean
it more like you have a love affair with
the ocean i do yeah yeah when we go to
skokie i'm gonna ditch you guys for
bagels you'll never know where i am
we're gonna know where you are at the
bagel place
or in your parents basement
i'm gonna be in your
parents room all right
we're gonna crate you in your own in
your parents house would love to share
she's going to be creative
she feels safe behind
a fence screaming
that's a happy place let's move on to uh
wait there's a couple things okay when i
showed up to the museum first of all the
shangri-la museum is it is absolutely
gorgeous it really is like amazing and
naveed was so nice for showing us around
it was really awesome they have a
foundation there they show us they were
showing us a bunch of new artists that
they housed there which by the way if
you can get that
position as the artist living at this
they have a playhouse doris duke was
like
there were there's some shady maybe
there was some slavery in her family's
history stuff like that
but other than that if she was being
well mildly a good girl yeah some
looting stuff like that she was a woman
who liked to spend some money and i can
enjoy that
i do like that about her but i will say
this okay so when i show up to the place
todd and i are driving around we got our
own car convertible range rover it's
really cute
we had the top down once
it rained on us but it was worth it
anyway so we go um we go to get there
and we can't it's like a weird hidden
away place it doesn't look like a museum
so we're driving around there's this guy
just like sitting outside in front of
the gate yeah and we drive around a
couple times and i'm like dude hi are
you and he goes it said something like
we said your name kalaila and i was like
okay so then he's like i got you
something and he's like giving us stuff
and i'm like who the [ __ ] is this guy
and he's cute he's attractive enough
that i'm not like i haven't screamed
stranger danger too hard right but todd
and i are not getting out of the car
okay he gives me crab he gives me crab
legs chips
yeah flavored chips which is really a
thoughtful amazing gift but to come from
his strangers
it was surprising okay so you thought he
was a stalker that's just happened i
went to kalila say what time we were
coming here or something on something oh
you were scared
why did i he didn't bring me a present
did you guys both get pregnant we both
got gift bags from nick yeah what was in
it um he got me filipino treats he got
me shoes
um
but he got her a bunch of stuff like
birthdays
birthdays i got crab like potato chips
okay let's just but but listen
hey do you remember that carrot thing
you refused to eat yeah he brought you
dim sum [ __ ] he did he brought you and
the dim sum was so good where was that
place i want to go back to that please
it's in chinatown it was so good anyway
so he brought us all these gifts and
stuff like thank you could easily have
been poisoned
i am looking at him and finally i just
text the group i go who is this man i'm
speaking to you and chloe goes oh that's
my friend nick the jeweler i go oh nick
the jeweler i go okay because he was
like let's smoke weed i got i thought
you were making a joke who is this man
i'm talking to and i thought it was todd
oh that's funny
[Laughter]
like she's fine yeah no no but he was
great he ended up being really cool and
hung out with us he's the best thing
yeah he was great and
nick you did not bring us jewelry
the whole time you kept telling him like
look i'm thank you for the gifts but
where's the i want jewelry and i i stand
by this nick what's next instagram um
and underscore potash and underscore
potash follow him it's so good you will
be seeing his his
jewelry on our body soon right nick
right nick
um it was really cool but you should
check him out check out the museum we
did have a lot of fun but anyway so then
we go to another museum after we drop
esther off nick hops in the car it's the
four of us i had no idea they were going
out to another museum ama amazing
love it keep carry on
it would have been fun with her there
yeah it would have okay yeah anyway no
one told me but he went in the
i'm sorry the baby rode home with a
crying baby let's be clear
in one of the rooms there was an exhibit
oh now i get to hear about how wonderful
the museum was it was honestly it was
amazing it was amazing
yeah it should have been called the slug
museum because it was right up our alley
we went into a room my friend had an
exhibit there my friend she's an artist
her name is nicole nolane she's amazing
there's a geodesic dome there and it was
uh a whole exhibit basically to um
around the mauna kea protest it was
beautiful it was really beautiful but
there was vr we did virtually we had
virtual reality um but
annie and i bonded over something and it
was not a good thing that we bonded over
wait i feel like we need to
like end nicole's part because nicole's
part was so good so nicole we went to
this dome and you can see the virtual
reality of this land it was really
beautiful and big island yeah
okay yeah i guess i sort of loved it
yeah well i was at the big island last
week so but we did that i know without
us and this is your payback but we did
that after we went that was a palette
cleansing
after we went into another room that i
would like to call the rape room what
that was without you we went into the
rape room
so there was a there was a
a rape log where you like log your rapes
yeah i mean it couldn't have been more
before you enter a room there's a book
there where women people have talked
about when they've been violated
whatever whatever and then
which is kind of our podcast i was like
you're ripping off of us
but
annie goes in there and there's like a
thousand like flowers around it's really
beautiful it's a red light and annie's
like i think i've been unraised raping
me
and then we went so then we went and saw
the land but i was looking into the
distance thinking there may be like a
little raping happening in the vr after
what we've been through
they also had a tent they had a homeless
person come in and recreate their camp
inside the
museum yeah so then later when our
friend nick missed his trip back to
hawaii i was like there is a tent in the
museum you can probably sleep in yeah
nick that was where's the jewelry
where is the jewelry neck he's like it
would have been so weird if i brought
you guys jewelry it's like no nick
that'd be weird
it's actually weird you're a jeweler and
you brought us
not jewels
oh how about when he gave me the weed
instead of you you
i watched through the windshield wait
that was the gift he got you was the wii
no annie took it he's it was for you
apologized profusely oh my god it was
for me that was the gift for you was the
weed oh this is crazy
she goes that weed was for me and i did
and i was literally i'm sitting in this
car like this you guys have never
treated esther like that have i ever
have i ever treated esther like this
shaking i'm shaking oh i'm so sorry
ma'am it's for you i'm so sorry ma'am
i gave it right back to you i was like i
need something soft to hit her in the
head with
um listen that's not what happened but
that's no it's okay i don't know
apologizing you were high and then you
had the paranoia of edibles wow that is
not true i watched her from
here's what happened i watched him give
me the weed he walked she wasn't fearful
he said something to annie and annie
goes uh-uh and she looks up at me and
i'm like no it's yours ma'am
she held you up at gunpoint
because you know i'm right i saw you go
march over like a garage shoulders first
did my army crawl over
[Music]
i was shocked i was floored i was
knocked to the ground my knees were weak
when i found out that he gave the joints
to esther not me i fell to the floor and
i army crawled to get what was mine just
a moment before george and carlos had
witnessed me getting in the car with a
big smile on my face guys i got this
weed for us and then i go oh
yeah no esther wanted to smoke weed with
george's baby you would have lost your
mind on our car ride over there because
um the baby was sleeping so george we
couldn't talk well not only could we not
talk um the the sounds that we're
playing were baby mozart so that baby
could stay asleep and then
you [ __ ] up
you made a big mistake and i remember
thinking to having a moment to myself
i'm like yes this is the hawaiian trip i
have dreamed of my whole life it's just
for george to [ __ ] this up more it's so
crazy it's like george's wife has been
trapped in a hotel yeah
in the pouring rain with their kid where
they could just be at home
in the pouring like they try sunny at
home too she could just be having a
regular life george is like no we're
going on a
vacation it'll be a work vacation be fun
and then nothing
he's been able to do nothing
[Music]
esther what up how many free trial
subscriptions so many end up costing you
hundreds of people know about it's bad
honestly esther you're supposed to be
managing this for me because it's wild
it's out of control i signed up for
something other day i went oh no it's
just the the fact that we have to
remember to unsubscribe
in a week i love it just reminded me
that i forgot to end my subscription for
a plant app
you put it on the plant and it tells you
if you need to water it or not i have
one plan i did it one time i found out
what the plant was called how much to
water it forgot to i spent 72.99 for one
year
for one that hurts but true bill saved
me from doing it again
no i agree i i love true bill it is
definitely like save me a lot of money
true bill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions you don't need want or
simply forgot about like all three of us
and on average people save up to
720 dollars a year
that's ridiculous mine's they're at a
one okay
and it's at the end
because companies make subscriptions
hard to cancel drupal makes it
incredibly simple just link your
accounts and true bill will cancel your
unwanted subscriptions in one tap and
your true bill concierge is there when
you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to you
guys don't fall for subscription scams
like all of us have start canceling
today at truebill.com
trash tuesday go right now truebill.com
trash tuesday it could save you
thousands a year truebill.com trash
tuesday okay who isn't like extremely
stressed out around the holidays i feel
great at ease but
it's because of calper cbd honestly
between orchestrating travel plans and
thinking about seeing my family like i
need help i need a little help yeah and
i'm a hostess like the amount of work i
host my family for chris christmas
that's about 25 people i usually have to
um find a caterer for all of these
things you guys got to call your mom to
cater for it
that is hard to call your mom
the holidays can be a little less jolly
than we'd like between orchestrating
travel plans hurting the kids around and
pulling off all the shopping in time we
could use a bit more of that all as calm
all as bright vibe we hear so much about
with caliper cbd you'll feel better
before you've finished your cocoa so
with most cbd it's actually impossible
to know when that you'll actually feel
the full effects but caliper cbd powder
acts fast and i mean really fast as in
30 times faster than cbd oil giving you
all the benefits of cbd in just 10
minutes in fact caliper is the only
clinically proven cbd brand on the
market and because it's a dissolvable
powder instead of an oil it mixes
completely into any food or drink with
no grassy taste or oily residue this
holiday season be your marius with
caliper cbd get 35 off your first order
with promo code trash at tricaliper.com
trash try it risk free for 30 days if
you don't love it they'll give you a
full refund
that's try caliper.com trash don't
forget promo code trash for 35 off your
first order
the only reason we really want to go to
the strip club is to see carlos and
george at the strip club not carlos i've
never seen you at the strip club
he gets does he get boners he gets so
professional he gets into like carlos no
he like knows what he's doing he's like
i made it rain on stage i immediately
went to the atm he took out a bunch of
money we know you didn't make it rain
with semen
because you have to have a boner he
makes it wait what's the boner issue
because we can't give you a boner
there were four cameras on me
baby time is money the cameras are
rolling right right well hawaii the
crew's gonna go home george has a baby
we can't be here forever wow
this got turned into listen
oh my gosh you know what i realized you
know what i realized
i know what i was my camera do you know
what i realized when you go listen
[Laughter]
i don't know why there's an issue about
whether i can get erect or not fly you
out here for you to cover my [ __ ]
camera you're on the line it gives you a
hand job
you don't cover esther's camera
you're on the there's a wide angle check
part of the check you cover her from the
sun
you cover her with a blanket when she's
cold you do not cover her camera thank
you
sorry carlos the commenters relax it's
just i have really really baby soft
hands and i don't think that any penis
should really miss this experience of my
soft hands that's all i'm saying
everyone deserves it it's on camera it's
daytime there's like a husband back
there it's a whole thing
like
did you not want to get a boner looking
at the husband
it's hot it's so much pressure no don't
worry this is a this is a bit everybody
yeah just what we're seeing before you
these are actors these are trained
crisis guys
no i don't know this is real no no
emotions are real here but i will tell
you i think i realized that last night
when i went in you i think you can't
really unrape anyone and i think what i
learned was we even though it uh it took
my rape away it gave it to carlos yeah i
need a lawyer in the honolulu area i
felt very rape but i feel like these
outfits have raped us
yeah [ __ ] you pete what the hell also um
i would actually look so there's
something that i wanted to talk to you
guys about get your opinion on so i read
this thing that um people don't actually
choose partners our bacteria chooses our
partners
so it's like if we have a bacteria match
like what's in our mouth
um that's who will determine what we're
attracted to
so basically have you ever been with a
guy you really really like but he's
constantly giving you utis and it's
constantly you're feeling very beastie
yeah
julian homeless julian well that was
that because of a hygiene problem or
just julian was uh yeah like well he was
uncut and i don't think he was uh
doing enough of the baby he was
he was storing some he was like fancy
cheese he was like an esther you know
what i was like just trying to listen
and just be innocent
you are an innocent i because i've never
had one where i'm repeatedly getting oh
i have i've had partners i've just like
they're so high i love when esther's not
can we get high
can we smoke some weed yeah we can wait
okay we have to talk about the body
count no before body count about the
bacteria thing okay i want to know like
are we attracted to people that smell
like us taste like us yeah um
don't give us constant like i don't know
if they smell like us because wouldn't i
be attracted to my twin brother if it
was like us it has to be a little
different right yeah complimenting
compliments right you're right you're
right we're not trying to bang our hot
ass twin bro yeah
would you be so upset if esther and i i
know he's married but like if we just
happen to accidentally sleep with your i
actually love that really if my sister
was cool
that creeps me i'm like
ugh
like that's like incest to me what for
you to hook up with my brother yeah
that's like creepy to me i think you
would think my brother was hot because
you are a little attracted to me
you are you have been for years look at
her she's like i'm busted [ __ ] what do i
do i just laugh pretend like it's a joke
i'm high oh no i'm high
she's driving
is that you driving you're back on the
big island
the inedible's driving being pills ready
to go to sleep forever
now that everyone knows she's eating
herself out oh no
she's good
you you don't have any floating ribs it
seems so you probably can't eat yourself
out i cannot eat myself out you we are
flexible you are did we not did she not
have any floating ribs like us she's
like so tucked in here i bet you're just
the perfect woman
can you try there's not a chance let me
try i know i can't
try i wish she's going to be able to do
it yeah if
oh you're very close to being able to
way closer than me but that was a long
way this is this has to push my head you
got to push my head in annie what if she
give me an assist what if i broke her
knack so when she died
i'm out of here
that was what you were doing
i have no one escaping okay so i don't
know i mean
i'm trying to think if i've had a
boyfriend that smelled really bad
probably they probably wouldn't become
my boyfriend i think what's prompting me
prompting me to ask this question is
that um i've been with dudes that are
just so complimentary like my vagina
feels amazing after and i've been with
dudes where it's like no matter how in
love i was with them we just weren't
sexually like our bacterias were not
matching well together where i've
constantly gotten like just you know the
feminine the jinx you know
i i
look i like where you're going with this
but i actually think that you're just
mixing two different things that are
happening like i think that the guys
that you were hooking up with were the
bad yuckys there were just hygiene
issues like you i don't think so
i don't think you got to pee after sex
you go
you know jarring sex yeah i think our
bacteria chooses our partners guys i
really do stand firm in that i think
there's something there where it's like
i know you love him but this is not it
like you are not complimenting each
other's flora but don't you think that
that's just for
children that's just because they want
your dna supposed to match to make the
healthiest child who knows but i mean
look we could just write it out if i
think i love someone so much i'm just
gonna
commit to a life of just bc easties yeah
i don't know it's the to have a
a daily cottage cheese i i don't know
that i i like that
the part of these infections that sex is
when it itches inside you yeah it feels
better when you know what i mean it's
like never mind oh when they they go in
and yeah jam it in there and it's just
itchy on the inside look ashley's
getting really happy about this oh my
god i was not look at her she's rubbing
look at you
oh she's fingering your yeast infection
oh do you use it as lubes use the
cottage cheese as a loser all right i
the i have rights i have rights
you stupid [ __ ] you had the bell the
whole time she already rang it once
earlier i don't even hear your belly
anymore it's like a dog whistle but the
opposite
i've become immune to her only other
dogs can hear me
oh cause you got the ugly outfit
no esther's body is it's a weird thing
that's happening yeah
i think you've always had it but you're
hiding anything that's happening but
your body is just hitting a really good
thank you good stretch wow thank you
yeah i think you're peeking
okay but you have to close to keep it
going yeah i'm not letting it come back
down
i started peaking at 30
uh
probably 36. let me see when that i feel
like i was starting to hit a peak
probably 28.
yeah but then i feel like i've i've
upheld it
i've had some lulls there but you know i
i feel like i come back down and i peak
again yeah so i'm like olomana i just
have multiple peaks
what's the best way to induce a peak
um you're not in you're a good life
shake-up a life shake-up like a bad
heartache a breakup
a friend breakup a lover breakup a
betrayal yeah you need a new lease on
life yes you need something that's going
to shake you up so hard that you shake
up the dust i had this
when this year oh yes you did that's why
yeah that's why you're hitting uh
your third is the greatest thing that
ever happened to you
this is my mission statement in life
that was like these are the best things
no but it shifts you in the right way
the trauma yeah
and then when you come stronger you
learn what you can get through annie we
had something that we were just gonna
talk about count body count oh yes the
body count yes this [ __ ] we're sitting
at around a pond by the way everywhere
in hawaii there's i'm on a pond i'm on a
i'm on a rock
i'm on a piece of coral actually oh my
god in that house the woman took the
coral from the ocean and put it in the
mm-hmm
daisy duke what's her name
doris duke
hair stick
oh it's a baby you made that chocolate
we could talk about the body count over
banana break okay perfect timing
do you wanna have a [ __ ] i'll eat that
later i'll have my banana now do i have
a papaya [ __ ] eating contest yeah come
on here
okay we're gonna talk about body counts
okay i hate that term
i see like the young kids are using it
what does that mean it's like how many
people you've been with and mine is
disappointing that's what that is wait
she says this to me last night at the
koi pond right she goes
she's like you know i realized my body
counts like surprisingly low now that is
a trigger warning for me when someone
says that to me i hate when my ho
friends come out as like only having had
sex with like seven guys it makes me
so mad where i'm like i have been
telling you everything
assuming this is like when you didn't
eat the [ __ ]
muffin [ __ ] this is like when you
didn't have the biscuit we're supposed
to be a goddamn team anyway i thought
we're on the same page wait here's what
i want to know
last night you guys were at a koi pond
talking about how many guys you [ __ ]
without me that's weird
that's weird you looked like one of the
fish
you were there esther
i just think that was weird and how you
should have the conversation again right
now
in front of me to watch while i eat my
banana
i mean let's be roster we would have
invited you would have said no yeah but
you just wanted the original invite
yeah
big tfti energy again esther i forgot
what's that
it's hard thanks for the invite oh [ __ ]
no
i'm cool we are on a trip together yeah
we shouldn't be looking i've invited you
to several things but look at annie
getting off look at annie loving that
i'm feeling left out and wanting to like
make you feel better yeah oh
god
so you were swimming in the koi pond as
annie and i were talking about her body
counts
you're a beautiful little fish in the
pond
and um yeah i think that mine is
sadly a lot lower than i would like but
it's not seven thank god it was it's an
acceptable number for me no it's in the
upper thirties and i think that uh
that's okay she wasn't a blackout drunk
ah
but i i nicolette
her friend nicole we were both like i
don't remember
but it wasn't that it's like can't be
that much but it's like i don't i was
drunk i don't remember i i kind of want
to i wanted that level of i don't even
know i can't even count like that's what
i want but that is you're almost there
you just didn't drink that much i know i
think it's because i was always in
long-term relationships so i would burn
a lot of rubber in between like if i was
single for six to eight months then i
would be like oh then i would you know
try to make up for it by like being with
like multiple people in one day but then
i just never got to that you know i
don't think mine's not much more than
yours i just don't remember the number
[ __ ] all right it's around there yeah
but anyways that was a conversation
like 20 to 40. and you know what right
when i said that esther your little fish
mouth came out of the pond and we fed
you and you are a happy little fish
thank you
what's your body count esther
it's not high
it's just all
you're like oh really they're very
questionable all of her account is
question marks
[Laughter]
we like dave and then the rest would go
what huh
what that guy
really
him i forgot about that one
i can promise you i've [ __ ] way uglier
guys than you
i don't know that ugly is the issue
ugly like because
i hate my really hideous fat disgusting
ugly scumbag ex-boyfriend but it's
because he was mean to my mom it's not
because he was fat oh that's the worst
it was because he was meeting my mom
what did he say he um well two times one
time he made her cry we were on vacation
he was just yelling that the internet
wasn't working but it was like an act of
god there had been a hurricane and
that's why the internet was down so he
was like screaming he was screaming at
the universe no he was mad at her oh he
was like why would you have us come here
with no energy she's like i didn't know
i wasn't gonna have internet
you know about the hurricane she started
crying and then he did it again we went
back to my mom got her ovaries out
and so i went to phil i was living in
new york so i went to philadelphia yes i
that's actually what i got injected into
my breasts that's why that's what
happened
she has ovaries titties but um
no it was quiet to see it she showed me
pic but so we went to go like i went to
go take care of her and he was like
he's gonna study the ovaries that you
came out of
like what did they do no they're over
those overuse let's move on from this
[ __ ]
i used it today
well i used it last night you know what
i'm talking about manscaped i stole my
boyfriend's manscape you guys if you
didn't buy your man manscape for
christmas you want to do it now it's not
too late it is the best thing you could
do for yourself actually it's a good
stocking stuffer oh boy
manscaped created the ultimate groin and
body trimmer by focusing on creating a
comfortable grooming experience their
fourth generation trimmer features a
cutting edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents so we all know the
men in our lives need our help manscaped
we'll make it safer for them i feel like
it's helping us honestly and we're fine
with hair we just need that hair a
little bit better groove it can't be
between my teeth okay i have floss
already just make it like respectable
before you know and not just even down
there up here too take care of your
beards guys and your weird neck hairs we
know
say goodbye to beard hair around the
sink because the trimmer is waterproof
esther did you know that oh thank you
[Laughter]
time to get him to shave in the shower
and while he's in there make sure he has
the new ultra premium body wash from
manscaped to leave him feeling and
smelling good their body wash is a
perfect addition to his self-care
routine it's also infused with aloe vera
and sea salt to keep skin feeling clean
nice and moisturized i do think it's a
super thoughtful gift for a guy because
it's like self-care but it's masculine
um and also it's like hey this is for us
later
you guys can get 20 off and free
shipping with the code trash
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at
manscaped.com and use our code trash
upgrade his 2022 self-care routine with
manscaped
he was
meeting my mom again he went he was like
i'll make it up to her and then he was
mad that she wouldn't watch tv a tv show
he wanted to watch oh gross she was
already watching her baby-ish no he's a
disgusting fat slob he's scum he's an
idiot he shoves food into anyways back
to my ugly [ __ ] yeah
um i'm yeah i think that you cannot
possibly beat the amount of ugly dudes
mine's so can i just show you how ugly
this guy is she knows how ugly it is
yeah he's he's number one the ugliest
i'm not gonna if he lost weight his face
would be ugly
this is the christmas episode
and we're gonna do the jingle bells of
the past now all of a sudden they don't
want to talk about their exes i finally
have a good story about a gross fat
actually i was thinking now they're like
oh we don't want to call them today no
we don't want to talk about them today
yeah i'm doing this is the jingle balls
you guys don't want to be a christmas
present all of a sudden this [ __ ] has
been in christmas past the whole time
yeah i truly i honestly have been and
how do you feel about that do you feel
over it what you're passed you're done
with it i got unraped yet last night
this was i wish esther was there thanks
for the unraping it really was a magical
moment between annie and i i have to say
we didn't log our rape in that book we
didn't log our rapes it's like you could
we should have just put uh the uh well
we'd still be there today oh my god we'd
still be there today
but what if we just left the url to the
podcast
you wanna hear our rape stories
we got 41 episodes
we have uh some clam de canes for uh
christmas
here's what i wanted do you know what i
want to start though
i want to start on the show eating good
food i want to start getting weird foods
that are from different places and
highlighting how good they taste
i want or they have to be alive did you
switch places with esther that's what
she's been saying since day one no but
she doesn't want it no she wants to eat
cheetos no esther's like i've never
tried cheetos that was esther's idea
so do an unbagging of the chip we've all
eaten i'm talking about like okay nick
our
jeweler who's gonna be giving us jewelry
soon
very good nice expensive jewelry for
free and we're gonna wear it and tag him
um our jeweler friend he did weird
research and got like kalila her
favorite snack oh my god he got me sweet
corn how good were the sweets i heard
all of them i'm sorry it's okay he got
me choco star he got me the greatest
like filipino hits like the snacks from
my childhood really good but that's the
thing you ate them all
i hate them all she really did eat my
whole bag of sweet corn let me tell you
did i eat them all
you ate them all
no no esther's favorite place
what did you go shopping yesterday not
at all no i'm sorry you brought that
puffy jacket yeah
esther has a wind the fullest winter
jacket she's the only one that thought
it might snow in hawaii also shout out
to um annie for drawing my abs these abs
are courtesy
oh god are they gone they look good
though okay her her torso is so much
longer than mine drawing her abs i
really realize like are anatomy i have
giant protruding ribs that look like
titties so do i but my ribs start just
lower than yours
yeah they've always got longer yeah i
have worse going what do you think it'll
be like if we all go to a strip club
like who's going to be doing what who's
getting i feel like it's never going to
happen no no no no no okay can i just
say something things are going to happen
i just think what happened here is we
thought we all thought someone else was
in the lead and no one was in the league
and that's what happened so
um george you are fired it's so weird
for you to be here with your replacement
carlos but carlos you are now
the sole producer of this podcast
but the first thing about being our
producers you have to get a boner on
camera right now
just kidding please don't um
please no no no but i think that that's
what happened i think in the future we
now have plans
and we need to go places we need to like
have we i know we have like slugs out
here that want to like show us their
hotel or show us their like cool
excursions and stuff like that we need
to like plan it with our people well
here's the thing when it's like when
it's hot when it's raining this hard
it's also hard to hike of course yeah
it's not very so it's like basically all
of our plans were sort of um
we're loose hiking plans yes
you know it's very weather dependent but
okay so strip club
we're definitely going we unsuccessfully
went to one last night or successfully
did not even bother we were talking we
just didn't know we didn't plan it we
didn't do that we didn't used to be like
the cars picking us up at this time
we're going what is what time is good
because pm people are already getting
tired too late
but strip clubs don't get like popping
right to like 10 30. we do need to just
get up you need to take adderall or
something [ __ ]
she's a guy she can't take adderall or
can we give you a nap are you a nap
person but after you're asleep you're
not coming you're not getting back i can
hold you in my arms and walk you into
this vaginas and boo i think that's
11. no i can do this i have offered you
to carry you in my kangaroo kangaroo
pouch this whole time oh that's actually
so cute well yeah yes my little randy
bag i wish i feel like i need to use the
bathroom go use the bathroom go go do
you think your periods leaking yeah
in a santa suit
on our front side it's a great color to
accidentally period on esther
cramatam bring it back to show us
we'll blur it out carlos go get her
tampon
carlos take her tampon out so i just
when we go to the strip club this is my
like mission statement for the strip
club when i go to strip clubs i get very
uncomfortable whoa i think i don't like
lean in i'm like there's a vagina on me
like i'm never i want to like get a lap
dance and i want to lean in i'm a carlos
he's a pro
he he knows what he's doing at the strip
club i've been to lots of
carlos in a confident position for once
annie here's a trick
you just have to assume it's just like
annual bar that's what i do i walk into
a strip club and it's just
like a boardroom meeting i just i think
it's like i get self-conscious or
something but i'm not i'm perfect with
us you'll be fine wait i have to say at
the strip club last time esther did
witness one of the black like bodyguard
dudes give me a fist bump like two hours
in he could just say he knew you because
you're a regular
it was in new york but he just knew that
i got it
or was that him going i'll give you my
lap dance in the back
he's like you can have sex in this she
marked me with poison
here's a [ __ ] fun topic that george
wants me to talk about what i want to
talk about what we're talking about
before too about okay there's this
tennis player his name i don't know how
to pronounce his last name but i think
it's nick kyrgios this tennis player is
taking a career hiatus because he says
he gets too horny on the court
i have that problem at my job too
when you're in court
when you're a professional court watcher
she just sits in the audience
slips sliding around gushing
i actually it's funny you said that
because i had to stop playing tennis
because of the opposite problem i was so
dry down there i was chafing
todd literally we were playing test and
one time i was just like we have to go
now my thighs are bleed like i was like
in so much pain because my tennis skirt
had written up
and so i think i need to get a little
horny before we go in so i can slash
down on this
wait but weren't you tennis girl for a
year i was tennis girl for about one
month i was around for that i didn't
know why are you acting like you this is
surprising you're just remembering i
don't remember any like extra crust
flying around
the regular amount
flying crust that's what they say kala
what's have you ever gotten too horny to
work
okay here's the thing about women like
we we don't have spontaneous arousal
like man men could look like a [ __ ]
banana tree and then just have a bomb i
pulled over once and had to masturbate
on the side of the roads were you in
molly's
no but it was like it was a weird time i
was also living in the car that was when
i was living in the car so it was a lot
more convenient yeah you were jerking
off at home yes i was at home you were
at home okay so that makes sense no i
was looking at my sublime poster over
the passenger side window i'm i'm all
reactive arousal like you have to do so
you have to yes i feel like something
like no i that's not me what do you need
the person to do
i need the person to here's what i
really because i'm really like squat
kind of and lean back with their head on
a shell
here's what
i'm really bad i'm getting horny i'm
really bad with um eye contact so when
someone knows how to look right now oh
my god tickle
that'll get me good eye contact good eye
contact well like strong like wait we've
talked about the lean on here have we
talked about the lean i cannot get
comfortable on the bench yeah the one
always makes me soaking wet what's the
lean when they lean in they lean it's
from i think it's from the 90s it's from
jordan catalano but it's the lean in
they lean into you they they take your
personal space you're against like a
locker or something you know and they
lean into you and they're hovering over
you and they say something not sexual
like what like they'll just be like you
have paper clips did you have a paper
clip and then you're like oh
it's really good yeah because it'll be
too much if they said something sexual
you'd be like you're already in my space
wait so earlier while we were taking a
second banana break wait we're taking a
second
by the way because jordan is like a
second your
cavendish bananas is whatever your
outfit is are you would you like a
second one
little girl
you leaned in
i hope i just transmitted deal wait what
did i miss why do we need a second
banana break oh here here's why your
cavendish bananas are not on brand with
island life so cara has some real cara
has some specials
banana break because kara has special
bananas that uh well they're not special
they're just you know what i mean
variety yeah
but they are special oh my god we're
waiting let's give you guys the clam de
canes it's a candy clamity why do you
sound like you're on prices right that
sounds like and how many of the candy
clam is it clam or chlamydia it's
special for the other oh my god look at
these little munchkins in the
philippines
what is that
it's better banana it's very sweet it's
white oh it's so cute esther doesn't
want it what is that it sounds if you
don't say it right it sounds fully
racist if you don't say everything i
teach you
got it
well that sounds racist
this
do oh my is it's all charred
congrats on your penis size it's so cute
ah it is sweeter it tastes like kind of
like a grape
oh it's smells these are my favorite
it's good
can we get these now for banana breaks
yeah we need them imported
they're hard to find at home george that
won't be a problem for mr george
oh my god small bananas only here we're
not coming to work
now i got replaced by carlos earlier
this episode so now it's his problem
here we go carlos isn't is his problem
is the short squat things what were we
talking about in the corner in secret
over there that we're trying to talk
about over here when you when you bang a
guy and he brings
his the energy from like what he learned
like he brings his moves and he brings
moves that are detailed to another yeah
you learn those on some other bitch's
body whatever you learn that you have to
curtail for another woman is not going
to work on us you have to start from
scratch you have to start now you got to
get to know our bodies we're very
different what might have blown her mind
is quite likely will not blow my mind no
or make me blow my head oh okay my body
away from you
and the direction away from you okay
i guess what i learned on kalaila i
wouldn't bring it over to you annie
you're finishing on me
i thought it was the open
oh my mic i almost spit into my banana
and there was a fly eating it oh esther
oh my god a fly that came around and
then stood
was it from the inside of the banner it
wasn't even a fly if it comes from the
outside just know that this camera angle
you have something good later
oh my god she's getting cocky
that's cocky behavior a fly landed on
your banana and you scream that's not
good enough
i just can't imagine you could ever
really survive in anywhere tropical
because flies are a thing esther
look you don't really learn to do this
you do this you just do this
the problem is i'm not scared of it i
almost bit the fly and i don't want to
eat a fly i know you girls love eating
flies i don't like them she's a
refugee to eat flies
that's so mean to say to her
and she's in her and she's in her i had
to eat fly's um stance
that's her refugee id flies dance
she's in it look at her oh my god that
is so [ __ ] funny it looks like a look
she's just they're ready to catch one
she's hungry
it's a protein for the day she needs her
protein for the day so she can keep
climbing i ate two bananas today can i
get paid twice
esther thinks there's like a payment
tree there's like a big guy i get paid
for two episodes today did you see how
big um arlene's banana
her money tree was in her house oh my
god arlene's money tree was huge i've
gotten money trees they've never lasted
more than a week
that's why our money doesn't last more
than a week but you know what
i should pay someone to water it that's
the most gangster money move
to pay someone to just come to water my
one money tree so your money tree loses
you money no it will gain me money
spending money you got to spend money to
make money it's true
you don't know nothing
i got to teach you i know everything i
don't know nothing i know that means i
know everything too negative is equal
someone punch her in the face now carlos
you're my handler smacker
slapper with your dick
what if what if when carlos was bringing
his dick towards you a fly landed on it
would you freak out why would he praise
tector because i told him
i would freak out for others
the smell
congrats on your new job by the way
carlos
[Music]
he's he's been assaulted by the three
female stars carlos now would you say
pick up your mic
i want to i want to make this very clear
for you guys he is our crisis actor and
we should probably get this out the way
did you feel at all violence i'm a
christian i try to yeah
also our producer so get with it all
feel violated crisis
crisis when on my birthday when i um
touched your penis from afar with a
wooden cane
yeah you felt violent and annie is
surprised that i didn't immediately get
hard from that just okay so i'm
surprised you didn't get one of esther's
lawyers on board
i try to get some moolah out of this
money train wait so what are you asking
me if i'm asking you like what were your
feelings did you feel at all resentful
towards me violated did you want to call
hr
no i didn't know we had hr but i do you
are hr we are no actually hr is hand rub
and that's like not when you call it no
i didn't feel resentful until like i
read comments and people were like are
you okay
i don't even know why you guys it was so
weird i thought it was like sissy's okay
no carlos has been one of my best
friends for 10 years i think people
don't realize that like he's not just
really interested no the people saying
that are guys that are mad that they
think it's unfair that rapists are
getting in trouble for raping women and
they go like if a guy did that to a girl
it's like well we've been right so many
times
he's a sex worker he's a sex worker he's
a sex worker he leads us to the strip
club yes you are you're you're our
leader should we name the podcast three
sixes
i think we not three sixes i think i'm
sticking to hot holes how [ __ ] this
faith-based podcast
we have three good options yeah
should we change it or keep it the same
because honestly skull slugs no skull
flock the faith-based
let them know what you love
um all right guys i think wait can we
just say the three the three ones we
have three sixes if you get that it's
because we're sixes and also six six six
esters is voting for
skull [ __ ] uh faith no that's mine so
mine is called [ __ ] the face a
faith-based podcast
[Applause]
that's what carlos is sleeping in a real
bath blood
carlos is like how did it get up into
the corner swingy you have to understand
what does carlos do i publicly apologize
to you no
kalyla you're making this
are you
is it because of the comments or
something i didn't even know there were
comments about it yeah i don't think it
was a bad thing like did someone say
something to you give me your dick put
your dick in my hand right now shake on
it
we're okay guys carlos and i are okay
nothing to see here nothing to cry about
no big deal he is somebody that i'm
gonna follow for the rest of my life
[Laughter]
i'm not the girl for the job
i believe it can get hard i'm just not
the girl i feel no way can i just say
something kaleila you give everyone a
boner
except for carlos no carlos is under
pressure yeah he's nervous yeah i also
have like lexapro in my system oh my god
these two
the lexapro twins
you guys are pros of the lex i'll tell
you that they are this is where their
professional comes in
who wants to close this honestly i don't
know if it's the weed but or the climate
but i have no i felt like this was seven
hours
this was the longest podcast of my life
it was off the rails i loved it
guys thank you so much for tuning in um
hawaii
is just a wonderful place it is we're on
the north shore it's gorgeous
kalila take us home
literally i'm
tired
i'm gonna do what i do best which is
just
bail on you guys without letting you
know thank you for saying that because i
was about to interrupt whatever you're
going to say you did best with that no
she's just gone she'll just there's just
like a car driving off with like like
all this cool stuff in it they're going
to like to surf or something like oh
there's just a surfboard driving off in
the way uh
no goodbyes just a complete bail it's a
filipino exit it is thank you guys so
much for watching this very special
christmas episode oh yeah merry
christmas
can you say it correctly this time say
it first melee
can i just say things i want to talk
about on the next episode so we are held
to them i saw the movie old i went home
and saw my parents i want to talk about
some real deep serious [ __ ] with you
[ __ ] okay okay
got it time to eat papayas i'll see you
guys later figure out how life moves on
all right guys love you happy birthday
enjoy your calendar carlos
[Music]
you